défi
communisme communisants
d'hommes semblables houngbo
alors bonjour à toutes et à tous vous
écoutez scopeo l'observatoire politique
je suis emilien nombreuses copé au et je
vous souhaite la bienvenue sur notre
chaîne pour l'entrevue politique numéro
13 aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux
de poursuivre cette série d'entrevues
politique avec monsieur paul melin
essayiste et chroniqueur et au programme
aujourd'hui le souverainisme de gauche
je laisse maintenant la parole à vélo
dit également membre de scopeo pour
qu'elle pose plus précisément la
décoration podcast
merci emilia
bonjour à celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent et surtout bonjour à vous
monsieur paul melin vous ne faites que
dire aujourd'hui de nous accorder cette
entrevue pour discuter ensemble de votre
vision du souvenir du souverainisme pour
la france en effet le 27 octobre dernier
votre mouvement mouvement pardon
souverain demain a fait paraître le
manifeste pour une france indépendante
écologique et innovante qui est
disponible dans toutes les librairies et
qui nous soumet plus de deux cent trente
propositions dans les domaines de
sécurité souveraineté nationale et
européenne écologie éducation diplôme
aussi et bien d'autres mais avant de
démarrer l'entrevue monsieur meslin je
vous laisse vous présenter brièvement
pour ceux qui nous écoutent ou pour ceux
qui nous écoutent d'où vous venez ce que
vous avez fait par le passé et aussi vos
influences politiques
vaste question bonjour à tous alors moi
donc paul melin j'ai suivi
pour vous refaire un peu la jeunesse de
mon parcours en quelques mots moi je
viens de bordeaux mon papa était
agriculteur biologique et mme hamamoto
petit jeu vivions à à bordeaux et nous
allions travailler que mon père souvent
une soixantaine de kilomètres de là
après un lycée public dans un lycée qui
s'appelle françois magendie pour les
bordelais moi je suis allé à sciences po
bordeaux
là j'ai un peu découverte ce qui était
là la vie politique le débat
intellectuel moi j'ai été président d'un
syndicat qui s'appelait qui s'appelle
l'unef j'étais président de l'unef à
sciences po bordeaux je me suis engagé
au parti socialiste au mouvement d
socialiste âgée tout ça allait un peu à
l'époque comme une forme de package pour
utiliser un horizon qu'on utilise
souvent aujourd'hui
et puis après un master en affaires
publiques
donc j'aime réaliser toutes sortes de
toutes sortes de stages et d'expériences
d'étudiants et puis après j'ai intégré
une école de commerce s'appelle l'essec
j'avais envie de découvrir un peu le
monde de l'entreprise savoir un petit
peu de quoi il en retourne et jean case
science pour n'est pas toujours très
préparé la professionnalisation
aux acteurs économiques donc c'était
quelque chose d'assez nouveau pour moi
pendant mes études à l'essec j'ai écrit
mon premier livre enfants de l'alae
construction portrait d'une jeunesse en
rupture qui est un essai que j'écris mon
meilleur ami n'ya jérémie forney
lui même ex à sciences po bordeaux dans
lequel nous décrivons la génération
15-30 ans avec ses failles ses doutes
c'est un portrait critique un peu au
vitriol notre génération avec un certain
nombre d'exemples sur la façon dont les
jeunes voyage est ce qu'on doit les
autres consoles voilà à la fin de ce
portrait un peu critique on formule des
voeux d'espoir pour cette génération
cet essai m'a permis de m'exprimer
davantage dans le débat public puis
après
j'ai commencé à écrire un certain nombre
de textes dans la presse ce soit dans le
figaro dans marianne un terrain et puis
progressivement le temps ce faisant je
souhaitais a souhaité m'engager dans le
débat intellectuel et politique donc
j'ai fondé souvent demain j'ai souhaité
qu'on écrive un livre collectif j'ai
d'autres nouveaux livres en projet et
puis en parallèle effectivement j'ai une
chance de chroniquer dans on refait le
monde sur rtl avec eric brunet tous les
mardis également les jeudis avec eric
brunet sur lci puis régulièrement sur
ces news avec sonia mabrouk et quelques
autres donc c'est une façon de
participer au débat public je crois que
tous ces médias me font l'amitié la
sympathie de recevoir donc libre à moi
d'essayer de faire des choses
intéressantes ce que j'espère j'arrive à
faire malgré tout et et voilà il ya
effectivement un engagement autour de
souverains demain autour de notre livre
qui comme vous le disiez une disponible
dans toutes les bonnes librairies sur
lequel on
fait aussi un petit peu le top 6 de ce
qui n'a pas marché pendant 40 ans on
essaie d'expliquer domaine par domaine
sujet par sujet tout ce qui n'a pas été
fait par nos dirigeants qui souhaitent
centre gauche ou de centre droit depuis
40 ans
face à ces critiques on n'a pas envie de
faire une critique sans émettre de
solutions propose un certain nombre de
solutions des solutions très concrètes
avec des propositions il y en a
effectivement 230 à peu près chiffré et
budgété donc voilà c'est pas seulement
un livre qui sera un livre programme -
un livre projet c'est un livre d'
analyse de décryptage et de propositions
parce que souvent vous savez quand on
fait un livre de critique j'en ai fait
rien dans mon premier livre on nous dit
mais vous critiquez vous proposez rien
c'est quelque chose qu'on entend
régulièrement alors non seulement aux
critiques au crédit beaucoup mais on
propose aussi beaucoup et je crois même
qu'on propose encore plus concrétise
donc voilà donc ce livre je l'espère
aura une résonance sur sur notre
élection présidentielle moi en tout cas
je m'y emploierai dans le débat
médiatique et politique et puis on
comprend en sorte que ces propositions
soient reprises pour notre beau pays
alors merci pour cette présentation en
tant que souverainiste je vous ai
entendu plusieurs fois par le passé vous
référer à l ouvrage de régis debray
éloge des frontières où on trouve
notamment cette phrase à propos des
frontières là est d'ailleurs le bouclier
des humbles contre l'ultra rapide
l'insaisissable et l'omniprésent ce sont
les déposséder qui ont intérêt à la
démarcation franche et nette dans ses
actifs et le territoire et la frontière
leur seule source de revenus
et dans ce trou dans cet ouvrage régis
debray décrit les frontières
comme nécessaire pour les plus démunis
alors que les classes les plus riches
profitent de la mondialisation
est en dedans la conservation de leurs
intérêts de classe à abolir les
frontières justement est donc vous quel
est votre rapport à la notion de
frontière et n'est-elle pas en cela
selon la réelle à la vision de régis
debray ortm que la gauche devrait
réinvestir
dans votre question
vous avez tout dit et d'ailleurs la
citation de régis debray est très juste
tous les travaux de régis debray mais
comme d'ailleurs d'autres comment
dirais-je
compagnons de route ou théoriciens du la
souveraineté nationale du souverainiste
de l'indépendance
part d'un constat assez simple à c'est
implacable
qui est de dire la chose suivante un
état un espace s'il n'a pas de limite
s'il n'a pas de bornes
comment peut-il se définir comme état et
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis la
nuit des temps les êtres humains sur
terre des limites des limites ils
organisent ils organisent au plan
logistique au plan humain au plan
culturel c'est la base c'est le
fondement de toute civilisation
peut-être que les seules civilisations
qui ont vécu par delà les frontières
sont les civilisation nomade
par exemple mais mêmes les civilisations
nomades d'ailleurs lorsque vous observez
dans les invasions barbares l'arrivée
des uns par exemple ou des vandales et 1
et les vandales ont tout de même une
terre d'origine ils font des invasions
dans le nomadisme il s'installe et
parfois ils retournent chez eux il ya
des exceptions par lego les wisigoths
sont installés dans la région de
toulouse ayant élu domicile mais voyez
ils ont recréé un royaume les wisigoths
avec des frontières de ce même dans les
civilisations aborigènes en fait vous
pouvez balayer dans l'histoire de
l'humanité à peu près toutes les
civilisations
elles se sont toutes construites et ont
toutes survécu avec des frontières ça
c'est un premier préalable à la question
même des tas de nations comme groupe
constitué donc les frontières sont
indispensables à l'idée d'état ça c'est
une première chose parce que l'être
humain l'homme a besoin de limites et
qu' au-delà des limites une limite c'est
par un monde d'un autre et que c'est un
besoin quasi anthropologique quasi
philosophique dans votre question il ya
un deuxième élément
sur le rapport entre la gauche et les
frontières et là effectivement
c'est un vrai sujet parce que la gauche
s'est construite historiquement avec les
frontières la gauche s'est construite
historiquement
avec les états nations avec les
frontières et par ailleurs elle les a
défendues elle les a défendus face à
ceux qui vous et les abaisser pour les
envahir ou pour coloniser fait
l'histoire de la gauche s'inscrit
fondamentalement
dans la notion de frontière après il ya
une néo gauche qui est apparue à partir
des années 60 70 avec le mouvement aussi
comment dirais-je non-violente pacifiste
avec le mouvement de la déconstruction
évidemment qui le surplombe et avec le
mouvement de la libération et cetera de
la libération des moeurs est arrivée a
été un stylet l'idée selon laquelle les
frontières étaient quelque chose de
passéiste de ringard
quasiment le fascisme parce que elle
supposait une délimitation est limité
donc une société sans limite et l
ambition de 7 mai au gauche la gauche
moderne la gauche contemporaine s'est
laissé avoir par ce piège tendu un piège
tendu par un certain nombre
d'intellectuels de philosophes
d'universitaires qui ont considéré qu
effectivement il ne devait plus avoir de
frontière que le monde devait être un
village que les cultures et les
singularités culturelles
n'avait pas de sens et qu'on pouvait
créer un grand tout un grand commun
sans frontières ni limites mais sans
frontières ni limites physiques et
géographique mais aussi sans frontières
et sans limite par exemple on voit
aujourd'hui que la théorie du genre avec
l' enveloppe corporelle avec les limites
biologiques plus de limites biologiques
plus de limites géographiques plus de
limites intellectuelles
tout ce qui limitait que ce soit les
lois écrites voilà il est interdit
d'interdire jouir sans entraves et les
interviews les entraves est en mal jugé
par cette néo gauche c'est devenu une
gauche d'enfants gâtés en rupture avec
leurs parents mais sans réellement
proposer quelque chose d'autre et donc
cette nouvelle gauche là s'étant
effondrées sur elles mêmes c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui elles étant en totale
déclin et qu'elle n'arrive pas à
regrouper les français
et donc moi je crois qu'ils trouvent
personnel que pour relancer la gauche il
faut repartir des frontier
corps jeu très bien merci alors comme
vous avez pu le constater nous faisons
cette entrevue sur zoom entreprises
américaines qui est devenu l'un des
piliers de nos vies depuis la crise du
provident malheureusement ou
heureusement ça dépend pour certains et
ça a surtout mis en évidence la
nécessité de faire émerger de nouveaux
acteurs du numérique afin que les
principes et valeurs de notre pays
soient respectés et donc selon vous la
france at elle les moyens et les outils
pour construire sa souveraineté
numérique tels que j'ai pensé à la
suisse qui a notamment l'entreprise
infomaniak ou bien cette souveraineté
numérique française doit-elle passer par
l'union européenne comme voudrait le
président maquereau ou où notre
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes
alors clément bonne emmanuel macron
déjà en prenant une souveraineté
européenne disons avec des géants de la
technologie du numérique français sont
déjà en rupture eux-mêmes avec ce qu'il
disait il ya quelques années ou avec ce
que disaient les dirigeants successifs
jadis
nous n'avons pas entendu jacques chirac
nicolas sarkozy mme françois hollande
veut dire que nous devions avoir une
affirmation
patriotique économique dans le domaine
du numérique la souveraineté numérique
n'a jamais été un sujet et parce que les
souverainistes que nous sommes
quelques-uns parce que les français qui
sont évidemment beaucoup plus nombreux
et beaucoup plus visible que nous mais
nous ne sommes que leur modeste
portelois ont souhaité faire savoir à
nos dirigeants que c'était étrange
d'utiliser uniquement et seulement des
produits manufacturés américains
chinois que la modulation faisait que en
france on ne pouvait plus produire quoi
que ce soit toute chose et que le
numérique et est parti aujourd'hui
légale fight est américaine et que leurs
homologues chinois et asiatiques ils en
sont venus à se dire les manuels macro
avec les membres y parle pur
opportunisme électoral eh bien on va
proposer nous aussi une souveraineté
numérique européenne enfin il faut quand
même faire la genèse de notre inaction
de ce point de vue là depuis des
décennies
le virage numérique la révolution
d'internet
elle a effectivement commencé il ya
maintenant un petit moment elle a
commencé avec des personnalités comme
mark zuckerberg pour facebook comme bill
gates pour microsoft les gens qui
étaient effectivement des talents qui
ont été rémunérés biberonné orchestrée
par les états unis d'amérique c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que les états unis
d'amérique
contrairement à ce qu'on entend dire on
réussit tout de même à demeurer une
grande puissance au début de ce 21e
siècle notamment grâce à la silicon
valley grâce à cette grande révolution
de nouvelles technologies les asiatiques
et les hadiths d'asie du sud-est les
cinq dragons la chine etc taiwan tous
ces endroits ont compris très bien
l'enjeu et se sont dit que s'ils
n'arrivaient pas à eux mêmes à créer une
alternative technologique face aux
américains ils seraient vassaliser pour
le restant de leurs jours et donc ils
ont construit des programmes pour
développer des choses moi quand je suis
allé à hong kong ou à shenzhen tous ces
endroits vous voyez la révolution
robotique est en marche ils font un
travail extraordinaire toutes les
entreprises occidentales qui ont été
délocalisés là bas on a exporté des
savoir-faire que les chinois ont su
exploiter travail et reprendre à leur
actif et aujourd'hui ils ont largement
les possibilités de créer l'ordinateur
du futur le smartphone du futur les
processeurs et les logiciels du futur
les seuls qui si vous voulez dans cette
sombre affaire depuis 30 ans n'ont pas
bougé le petit doigt c'est nous les
européens
parce que nous avons laissé passer le
train en marche nous nous sommes vite
tient les américains fabriquent ils
réfléchissent ils construisent nous
avons en bénéficier nous allons acheter
nous allons acheter leur matériel mais
nous n'avons droit nous mêmes faire
notre propre matériel c'est comme ça que
les entreprises européennes qui auraient
pu être des fleurons je pense par
exemple à nokia qui est finlandais
aurait guengat elles auraient pu être
des flots rang européen pour des pays
européens mais ça n'a pas eu lieu ça n'a
pas eu lieu parce que les pays rares
qu'européen la commission européenne dès
les hiérarques européens de tous poils
d'ailleurs quelle que soit leur
obédience qu'ils soient conservateurs
aux sociaux-démocrates ont considéré que
l'avocat on de l'europe c'était la lutte
contre l'inflation s'était les normes
environnementales et encore les normes
environnementales et les normes en tout
genre
c'était la construction d'une europe
commandez réel des règlements et des
normes des textes des doctrines des 3%
l'europe s'est trompé l'europe a fait le
pari de la rigueur budgétaire alors que
dans le monde entier on investissait
dans des secteurs d'excellence et
l'europe n'a pas investi dans des
secteurs d'excellence pire encore quand
les allemands et les français par
exemple tenté d alliance stratégique
industrielle ou autre elle était cassée
par l'europe donc non seulement l'europe
n'a pas été un facilitateur de
construction de notre souveraineté
économique aurait pu être effectivement
européenne mais pire elle en a été un
mauvais relais voire un limitateur donc
ça c'est grave après nous à l'échelle
nationale on peut pas non plus tout
imputer à l'europe
nous les français nous avons fait
quelques tentatives avec les technopoles
avec sophie nice sophia antipolis avec
des programmes d'innovation mais
malheureusement je soutiens évidemment
ces programmes mais ils ont été pour le
moins insuffisant par rapport à par
rapport à ce dont nous aurions eu besoin
pour concurrencer les américains ou les
chinois donc aujourd'hui et bien voilà
nous sommes au pied du mur il faut
relancer une construction numérique une
souveraineté numérique française d'abord
puisque l'europe ne peut pas le faire
moi j'ai une logique très simple tout ce
que l'europe pour le moment ne fait pas
ou n'arrivent pas à faire c'est à dire
tenir nos frontières c'est à dire lever
une armée c'est à dire
avoir une industrie de pointe eh bien la
france le fait c'est comme ça on pallie
au manque d autres après si demain
l'europe décident de commander ray de la
commission européenne mais comme grandes
priorités une relance par l'innovation
et met en place des grande coopération
entre des coopérations industrielles
très forte entre trois ou quatre pays
clés pour créer le google européen
évidemment même temps même en tant que
souverainiste mais je dirais même plus
encore en étant souverainiste
j'associerai la france à cela mais pour
le moment il n'y a aucun programme de ce
type à la france de le créer
vous avez commencé à y répondre à
travers l'exemple du numérique
votre votre idéal est celui d'une france
souveraine mais la france partie
retrouvée dans les années à venir
confronter un certain nombre de défis
donc notamment le numérique dont on
vient de parler mais aussi
des défis concernant la défense où les
problématiques environnementales et
caetera et cas pourra donc sans doute à
relever seul
et l'échelon européen il peut s'avérer
donc utile pour les affronter également
pour faire face aux autres grandes
puissances à voir en empire qui pourrait
la menacer
comment est ce que vous voyez cette
articulation entre une france souveraine
et l'échelon européen et pourquoi pas
une europe souveraine et est ce que
selon où il faut sortir de l'union
européenne pour essayer de bâtir une une
nouvelle structure ou est ce que vous
pensez qu'il est possible de la réforme
et de l'intérieur
alors je vais tout de suite sortir du
suspense en vous disant que moi je ne
prône pas la sortie d' union européenne
en tout cas pas tant que les français
n'auront pas décidé si dans dix ans cinq
ans 20 ans les français disent
maintenant ça suffit on nous promène
depuis trop longtemps et depuis
maastricht et l'europe nous apporte que
des ennuis eh bien je serai à ce
moment-là de ceux qui diront bien bon
les français ont tranché le peuple est
souverain dont il surprend l'union
européenne mais moi ce n'est pas
l'option que je retiens je crois que
votre question était très intéressante
des grands pôles économiques militaires
diplomatiques sont en train de se former
dans le monde
l'amérique du nord en est un de toute
évidence
j'ajouterai même à l'amérique du nord on
l'a vu avec la crise et sous marins
voire même avec la crise des pêcheurs on
peut associer le commonwealth et le
grand frère britannique probablement que
ce nouveau grand ensemble qui est une
émanation de l'occident anglophone est
un ensemble important
l'asie du sud est la chine et ses
partenaires est un autre grand ensemble
le japon est un ensemble d'associations
avec les états unis d'amérique
la russie en association par moments
avec la chine mais avec une politique
peut-être plus indépendante avec les
associations qui arrange les russes
et nous les européens l'europe continent
pas si on exclut maintenant depuis leur
équipe les britanniques même si je pense
qu'il faut pas exclure nous sommes un
autre bloc mais un blog qui pour le
moment si vous voulez se place dans une
dans une dynamique qui n'est pas une
dynamique de puissance qui est une
dynamique de tampon de puissance
d'appoint l'union européenne madame
vanderheiden n'a pas une affirmation
politique diplomatique militaire ou
industrielles capables de rivaliser
trois minutes avec les chinois ou
américains c'est ça fait mal entendre
pour l'élan qui seraient des européistes
confirmés ou en tout cas convaincu mais
c'est la réalité on le voit avec ce qui
se passe on en biélorussie avec monsieur
loukachenko et la frontière polonaise
l'europe n'est pas capable
on l'a vu avec un degas dans le vexin
utah d'affirmer une position qui soit
respecté par les pays tiers que pourrait
être la turquie le maroc ou la
biélorussie donc partant de ce constat
l'europe est défaillante
l'europe est défaillante après est ce
que pour faire face aux défis de demain
que sont et vous les avez rappelé je
suis assez d'accord
les la révolution numérique
le cadre de laquelle le cataclysme
écologique qui va vers nous de façon de
plus en plus ardentes les déséquilibres
du monde au plan géopolitique auquel
j'ajouterai l'immigration de masse et
les risques qu'elle fait peser et que
cette immigration de masse est
parfaitement liés aux autres sujets qui
nous traitions à savoir l'écologie et le
déséquilibre géopolitique
toutes ces menaces la nécessite une
grande force effectivement la france
c'est 550 mille mètres carrés ces 66
millions d'habitants bon
quelle force et quelle puissance un tel
ensemble à l'échelle du monde me direz
vous vous savez c'est cette secrétaire
d'état aux mines ce même plus agnès
pannier une hache et qui avait dit la
france d'une boîte de smarties et c'est
un peu ça la logique des macros nist
c'est à dire que ou des modérés de
centre gauche et de centre droit depuis
40 ans eux mêmes à la tête de l'état
considère notre pays comme une boîte de
smarties et par conséquent se disent
aurons tellement peu aujourd'hui on
pourrait se fondre dans la
mondialisation ou dans l'europe on
pourrait plus posé et c'est des fadaises
pour pesée n'importe quel négociateurs
internationale ou diplomates le dira il
faut d'abord pesé parce que l'on possède
bon alors là il faut faire l'inventaire
de ce que la france possède ce qu'elle
peut affirmer dans le 3è diplomatie du
monde deuxième territoire maritime
mondial
économie avec des secteurs d'excellence
comme le luxe l'aérospatiale
premier pays touristique du monde 1re
armée du continent européen c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut envisager la france
pas sur des histoires de on est un pays
arabe où on rit on doit s'associer à qui
que ce soit donc d'abord réaffirmer
notre puissance faire entrer la france
dans une dynamique de puissance
renforcée ce qui fait déjà notre
puissance est allé chercher par ailleurs
la france jadis était un grand pays
d'industrie textile c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a tous des
vocalises et la france doit redevenir un
grand pays d'industrie textile la france
a pris du retard sur le numérique mais
la france a su aussi faire le laser
mégajoule du bar par exemple où la
direction générale de l'armement qui
innove à des niveaux extraordinaires
donc il faut renforcer aller plus loin
et si vous voulez une fois que la france
recouvre plus de cette souveraineté de
cette puissance de son indépendance
reprend des fleurons automobiles aussi
je peux citer elle aura probablement une
autre place à la table de négociation
mondiale et nous pourrons avoir une
affirmation culturelle et politique plus
forte dans ce cadre là nous pouvons
évidemment mais nous le faisons depuis
la nuit des temps commercer échanger
travailler avec nos partenaires nos
partenaires sont nos alliés européens
notamment évidemment nous avons un
partenariat beaucoup plus important avec
l'allemagne et avec toutes sortes de
pays dans le monde donc c'est pas en
étant souverainiste que vous allez dire
tout à coup vous avez ça c'est un mythe
dont on affuble les souverainistes par
ce qui me dérange et dans les
mondialistes voudrait une caricature et
rentre donc c'est des miradors à
personne personne n'a dit ça et personne
n'a vécu comme ça depuis la nuit des
temps pas pourquoi ça commence
aujourd'hui
depuis gênes ou venise on sait qu'on
doit commercer si on veut survivre
évidemment un souverainiste responsable
et intelligent vous dira que nous avons
besoin de commercer avec toutes sortes
de pays dans le monde que nous pouvons
évidemment et que nous devons mener des
coopérations renforcées et donc si
l'europe est un marché
commun de 500 millions de consommateurs
utiles à notre économie au développement
de nos intérêts
notre avenir elle sera utilisé de la
façon la plus optimale qu'ils sont mais
comme nous pourrons développer des ponts
commerciaux et d'échangés culturels
académique économique avec nos amis
britanniques par exemple ou avec nos
amis américains ou avec nos amis russes
payer ou avec nos amis chinois avec vous
avec nos amis indiens comme l'a fait
donc la france doit pouvoir se choisir
les alliés qu'elle veut sans qu'on lui
dicte et je crois que pour le moment
l'europe mais n'est pas à la hauteur des
défis
alors à l'horizon des jeux olympiques de
paris de 2024 le sport va être mis en
avant dans le débat public or depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire l'activité
physique a été limité voire empêcher que
ce soit pour les enfants et les adultes
bien que l'on sache d'où l'importance du
sport pour notre santé physique et
mentale et dans votre manifeste vous
avez consacré une partie à
au sport comme principe d'équilibré et
du coup nous aimerions savoir comment le
sport peut jouer un rôle fondamental
dans l'avenir de notre pays pour
construire un pays fort innovants et
bien évidemment en bonne santé
ça c'est une question intéressante que
vous posez là parce que on parle
malheureusement assez peu du sport en
tout cas dans les politiques publiques
on en parle je trouve à mon goût trop
peu et quand on en parle on en parle mal
souvent on parle du sport vous savez au
prisme à travers le sport professionnel
on parle de sport quand la france je me
la coupe du monde pour faire simple où
effectivement vous en avez parlé quand
la france organise les jeux olympiques
moi je suis évidemment pas défavorable à
ce qu'on organise les jeux olympiques
mais je trouve très intéressant ce soit
pour notre soft power pour notre
rayonnement pour notre économie
d'organiser de telles manifestations par
ailleurs dans le livre je propose aussi
qu'on remette en place des expositions
universelles
oublier plus que les manifestations
internationales là aussi c'est un petit
pied de nez à ceux qui disent que le
souvenir le repli sur soi quand on
organise des expositions universelles ou
qu'on veut investir dans les jeux
olympiques c'est tout le contraire pense
que notre rayonnement notre capacité à
entretenir des relations saines et
équilibrées avec nos partenaires est
très important pour ce qui est du sport
moi je je suis un fervent un chaud
partisan du sport amateur
je pense que c'est là
l'issue est le salut de notre beau pays
effectivement le sport c'est la santé
l'équilibré
psychique physique intellectuel est
globalement un acte fou du sport et donc
je crois qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
les subventions par les collectivités
territoriales donnée aux clubs de sport
je crois que nous avons la chance en
france d'avoir un maillage territorial
d'associations sportives extrêmement
développé c'est une chance il faut
l'entretenir vous savez je suis en ce
moment même dans mon petit village en de
serre via 200 habitants
c'est 200 habitants vous avez d'autres
petits villages autour il ya un stade de
foot bal il ya des équipes qui font du
de la course à pied il ya des cyclistes
qui passe à côté de chez moi avec des
vélos de course en carbone digne du tour
de france voilà c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est mettre en place le
pouvoir politique doit être un
facilitateur
accrue du sport amateur
construction de pistes cyclables au
niveau local de plus en plus importante
je crois que c'est l'avenir moi je crois
énormément aux pistes cyclables je suis
un amateur de vélo par ailleurs et donc
je viens de gironde une piste cyclable
qui s'appelle la piste roger lapébie été
installé par le conseil départemental
qui était une très bonne initiative qui
a été fait sur une ancienne voie de
chemin de fer et je crois que toutes les
voies de chemin de fer qui sont plus
utilisés c'est le bon ben je suis aussi
un partisan du ferroviaire je pense
qu'il faut en remettre en tout cas
celles qui ne sont plus utilisables en
faire des pistes cyclables
investir dans le sport amateur au plan
économique le sport aussi comme vecteur
d'intégration et de connaissance de la
culture française parce que
malheureusement dans de nombreux clubs
de football et ses amateurs
dans un certain nombre de quartiers des
valeurs qui ne sont pas forcément les
bonnes il son véhicule et nous devons
nous assurer que ce sera des bonnes
valeurs qui seront véhiculés ça c'est
très important donc tout cela constitue
quelque chose de très très très très
primordial il ya aussi le sport à
l'école qui doit être réformé les
capacités qu'on doit pouvoir avoir
dès le plus jeune âge à inciter les
enfants à faire du sport pour leur santé
en faire de plus en plus on est à l'ère
de la révolution numérique technologie
delhomme sédentaires
aujourd'hui nous sommes de plus en plus
sédentaire nous n'allons plus
nous ne pouvons plus pratiqué de sport
en plein air bon tu pas contre les
salles de sports intérieurs bien sûr
mais je crois que les françaises et les
français doivent redécouvrir le plaisir
du sport en extérieur le sport nature je
lis aussi cela dans le livre avec la
question du tourisme des territoires de
la proximité vous savez même pour des
petits parisiens l'équipe parisienne où
des habitants de lyon ou de bordeaux ou
de nantes sortir un peu de la métropole
à mais de plus en plus les enfants en
classe vers leur faire découvrir le
sport avec des parcours dans les bois et
sert à leur faire découvrir la nature
par ce biais là
les valeurs du sport la cohésion j'aime
aussi beaucoup le rugby en région leur
apprendre la cohésion l'esprit d'équipé
la solidarité voilà je crois qu'on doit
mettre le paquet là dessus parce que la
vitalité d'une civilisation sa force sa
longévité réside en partie dans le sport
on parle énormément de santé souvent on
parle de santé plutôt au prix ou de
l'hygiénisme ne plus fumer dans
certaines zones de plus faire ceci ne
plus faire cela ne pas sortir sans son
pass salutaire moi je crois qu'il faut
aller surtout vers un sport de la bonne
santé et excella qu'on a pour moi un
vrai axe de développement de santé
publique j'ai même pas parler de
l'obésité mais c'est évidemment
parfaitement et
je vais
vous avez dit que là la question du
sport était peu
présent dans le débat public je vais
aborder une question qui est quand même
beaucoup plus débat dessus ça va être la
dernière question de de l'entrevue
donc l'écologie semble tenir une place
importante dans votre projet puisque
vous débutez votre ouvrage par une
introduction qui s'intitule pour un
souverainisme éclairé écologique et donc
pour vous quelle est votre vision de
l'écologie et surtout comment est-ce
qu'elle s'articule avec la notion
souverainisme et avec la france et
centralisées et girondines que vous
appréciez
alors
je crois que l'écologie
je crois que le souverainisme par
essence est écologique parce que la
mondialisation
quel modèle alternatif aux
souverainistes en vigueur aujourd'hui en
france et en europe poussent et on l'a
vu d'ailleurs avec la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pendant le coït à la mobilité accrue des
capitaux des marchandises et des hommes
c'est même là la définition
pour partie de la mondialisation par
conséquent pour donner un exemple très
concret très simple si vous si vous
mettez en place des barrières
protectionnistes si vous mettez en place
du produire en france si vous renforcez
les savoir-faire nationaux et bien
mécaniquement
le commerce mondial va baisser puisque
c'était l'économiste de ricardo qui
avait trouvé par les avantages
comparatifs et la division
internationale du travail que et bien il
fallait produire par des secteurs
d'excellence dans différents pays des
objets qui après pouvaient circuler dans
le monde entier
je crois que si l'on revient sur cette
théorie là bien sûr qu'il aura toujours
besoin de commerce mondial notamment
pour les matières rares pour les métaux
rares pour si vous faites une batterie
au lithium pour faire des téléphones
vous allez bien être obligé d'aller
chercher le lithium là où il est mais
autant que faire se peut la souveraineté
économique serait de nature à faire
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à faire baisser notre empreinte
écologique
que ce soit sur terre sur mer ou dans
les airs notamment par la relocalisation
des activités productives au pourtour de
nos de nos agglomérations ça nous
permettrait aussi d'ailleurs de
maîtriser la façon dont nous
industrialisant parce que lorsque les
usines de production sont en france ça
vous permet d'avoir un regard beaucoup
plus étroit sur les normes sociales ou
environnementales que si vous faites
construire vos paires de chaussettes ou
aux chaussures ou que sais-je nouveau
batterie aller bout du monde de toute
évidence le modèle des grandes firmes de
vêtements etc qui produisent au
bangladesh des t-shirts ou des pantalons
faits par des enfants dans des
conditions abominables des conditions
sanitaires dégoûtante des conditions
sociales dégoûtante des conditions
écologiques souvent très problématique
ben évidemment oui ce modèle mondialiste
qui nuit très fortement la planète
al'inverse lorsque vous remettez en
place des circuits coup de la localité
de la proximité du terroir et bien là
vous entrez dans un cercle vertueux qui
sera extrêmement positif pour la planète
donc il n'y a rien de plus écologique
que ce modèle là que ce modèle national
donc la souveraineté nationale elle est
profondément écologique à la différence
de ceux qui considèrent le monde comme
un village et qui veulent un monde
d'aéroport jamais fermé de cargo qui
transporte des conteneurs absolument
partout sur les canaux etc donc ça c'est
un premier axe de développement après je
suis consciente pour la question de
l'écologie surtout au niveau mondial la
france étant un petit pays au plan
géographique et au plan numérique nous
ne pouvons pas à nous seuls inverser les
tendances et là dessus je crois
effectivement que nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix et si j'en connais c'est
un plus efficace je me pencherai très
serré je n'en vois pas d'autre nous
avons besoin de coopération
internationale est là en cela les
accords de paris ou des choses comme
cela son miniature a essayé d'améliorer
les choses je crois que nous devons
parler en termes de diplomatie aux
autres nations importantes de cette
façon là je crois que si tous les pays
européens par exemple relocaliser leurs
activités on remettait en place des
circuits courts la chine produirait
moins de co2 puisque la chine et l'
usine du monde donc par définition en
agissant de la sorte vous participez
aussi à faire baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en chine et puis
expliqué à nos amis chinois que en
agissant pour la planète en agissant
pour leur développement pour leur marché
intérieur ils agissent aussi pour leurs
intérêts et que je crois que nous devons
aller vers cela après il ya d'autres
questions qui sont autres que la
production et que le commerce mondial
évidemment la question de l'énergie moi
je suis un partisan quand on a pas mieux
du nucléaire en france je pense que
contrairement à l'idée reçue des
écologistes qui est pensé que le
nucléaire cause des problèmes et
environnementaux alors effectivement il
ya la question des déchets et nous
devons tous frères au plan de la
recherche pour pour résoudre ce problème
qui est très important mais le nucléaire
n'émet pas de gaz à effet de serre au
prêt peut par conséquent
puisque c'est la source d énergie la
moins polluante que nous ayons
aujourd'hui nous devons miser sur le
nucléaire
moi en deux-sèvres côté de chez moi y'a
beaucoup de parcs éoliens ça défigure
l'environnement c'est une abomination
visuelle des artifices qualité des sols
elle ne tourne pour ainsi dire jamais
elles produisent de façon résiduelle de
l'électricité pour chez nous et vous
savez les éoliennes c'est voilà c'est
l'écologie des urbains des bobos on met
des éoliennes chez les ploucs c'est
moche et ils en ont rien à faire par
contre au point de la rue chez eux il ya
des jardinières il ya du caillebotis
donc ça ce modèle là de l'écologie
urbaine moi je lui tord le cou et je
pense que nous n'avons rien à faire avec
cette néo écologique et qui n'a
d'écologie que de nom parenthèse
refermée là dessus je crois
qu'effectivement le nucléaire et là je
suis plutôt de l'avis du président de la
république est un axe de développement
les limites centrale et
la recherche fondamentale
est très importante le nucléaire c'est
un secteur d'excellence pour nous les
pour nous les français donc tous devons
poursuivre dans cette voie ensuite il ya
un autre sujet qui est important que le
sujet des transports moi je pense que
nous devons développer des réseaux de
transport français de haut niveau
écologique je crois beaucoup aux canaux
je crois beaucoup au fluvial je crois
beaucoup je vous parlais tout à l'heure
du cycle armé je crois beaucoup et
cyclables dans les départements mais
vraiment à l'échelle de petits
territoires de départements je crois au
train je pas aux trains de proximité
jadis en france il y avait un maillage
territorial grâce au trinquet très
important donc ça c'est un axe voilà et
pour résumer tout cela je vous mets
quelques politiques sectorielles ou pour
l'écologie il faudra beaucoup d'argent
il faudra investir elle nous proposons
50 milliards d'euros tous les ans moi je
crois que nous n'arriverons à cela qu au
prix d'investissements très fort d'une
intervention de l'état et l'intervention
de l'état avec nos entreprises c'est
extraordinaire l'entreprise familiale
les entreprises de taille intermédiaire
des grands groupes qui peuvent
travailler de concert pour atteindre cet
objectif et que c'est à ce prix là qu'on
mettre en place une vraie écologie au
sein de notre pays enfin pour la
dernière question s'éloigne un peu du
sujet du souverainisme mais comme vous
l'avez dit en introduction vous avez
publié en 2019 avec votre meilleure amie
mais cornet les enfants de la
déconstruction on fait une analyse des
mutations de la jeunesse occidentale et
comment cette jeunesse peut-elle relever
les défis majeurs du 21ème siècle ce
n'est pas un secret pour personne que la
jeunesse a été un peu malmené ces
derniers temps même emmanuel macron l'a
reconnu en disant que c'était pas facile
d'avoir 20 en 2020 mais dernièrement on
entend beaucoup parler de la
surexposition à la pornographie et
hussain violente avec par exemple la
série squid games chez les enfants et
adolescents comment expliquez vous cela
mais surtout que faire face à cela
qu'est-ce que cela présage pour le futur
de notre pays car ces enfants sont
l'avenir de la nation
pour moi c'est le pendant ces squid game
tous ces trucs là sont le pendant de
netflix des réseaux sociaux etc de
choses qui peuvent pas depuis une
offensive voire de tik tok tout ça et je
crois que nous devons
isoler les enfants de ce fléau parce que
derrière des choses qui peuvent paraître
anodines comme effectivement des séries
télé américaines des jeux morbide ou de
l'awt des flots de pornographie il y a
une culture il ya une culture et cette
culture c'est la culture individualiste
mondialiste et en partie américaine mais
parfois ça peut être aussi d'ailleurs
asiatiques mais en tout cas c'est tout
sauf la culture française et les valeurs
que l'on veut promouvoir auprès de la
jeune génération
donc la jeune génération est une espèce
d'épongé
qui si vous voulez reçoit intègre et et
comment dirais-je si avec ce qu'on lui
apporte avec le substrat culturel que
l'on lui apporte est aujourd'hui la
grande faiblesse de notre civilisation
c'est un peu ce que j'essaie de
démontrer avec le livre les enfants dans
des constructions c'est la faiblesse du
substrat culturel intellectuel spirituel
qui est offert aux enfants quand je dis
en confiance juste comme plus qu'aux
plus de 40 ans ou 50 ans en tout cas aux
français il n'ya plus de substrat
culturel qui leur est offert par
conséquent lorsque une civilisation
décline lorsque le substrat culturel et
intellectuel n'arrive plus il ya plus de
sève qui passe dans le tronc de l'arbre
est donc s'ils arrivent du r une plante
invasive le long de l'arbre elle lançait
rehle arbres meurent c'était exactement
ce qui arrive à notre pays en ce moment
parce que l'arbre est trop faible il est
envahi par de mauvaises ondes par des
choses qui sont effectivement dangereuse
nuisibles et pour que ces choses
dangereuses et nuisibles comme celui de
genk tout comme
tik tok netflix ou la pornographie
puisse envahir l'arbre c'est parce que
l'arbre était malade et notre maladie à
nous c'est l'individualisme c'est la
déconstruction des valeurs c'est notre
entrée dans la mondialisation c'est le
renoncement que nous avons eues à une
affirmation culturelle éducative
intellectuelle forte pour nos enfants
moi je préfère qu'un enfant lise une
bande dessinées d'astérix et obélix par
exemple qui lui montre ce que c'était
que l'histoire il est truffé de
références historiques astérix et obélix
aucun garde tintin et milou en dessin
animé ou en bande dessinée ses parents
l'emmènent dans des musées locaux ou
voir du cinéma français même du cinéma
populaire du cinéma drôle
pas besoin d'une culture élitiste
parisienne où je ne sais quoi il n'ya
pas besoin d'aller voir de l'art
contemporain à 8 ans par contre il ya
besoin d'un substrat culturel et
éducatif
intéressant pour les enfants il ya des
mondes imaginaires pour les enfants qui
sont fabuleux qui sont porteurs de deux
très belles choses le monde de la
chevalerie le monde chevaleresque le
monde des pompiers le monde des
infirmiers et des infirmières de
l'hôpital il ya plein d'imaginaire que
l'on peut communiquer à des très jeunes
enfants plus tard on peut offrir aux
enfants le dessin patriotique le dessin
artistique c'est fascinant on n'a pas eu
le temps d'en parler là mais la culture
moi j'en parle très souvent on peut
faire de nos enfants des artistes des
créatifs voilà il ya mille choses les
cibles comme ça un peu à la va vite mais
il ya mille choses qui peuvent
constituer ce substrat culturel mille
choses qui seront française et qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec le substrat
douteux que nous offre la mondialisation
sur un plateau d'argent à coups de masse
culture à coups de média incontournable
et contre les cas nous n'avons aucune
espèce de mesures de protection de
sanctuary nation culturelle
voyez les russes ou les chinois par
exemple prendrait pas en exemple sur
bien d'autres sujets mais en tout cas
ils ont mis en place des barrières
protectionnistes culturel pour conserver
leur singularité culturelle en chine
gaouaoui chat il ya pas facebook voyez
il ya des des systèmes de communication
qui sont nationaux dans la moi je veux
bien qu'il soit européen ces systèmes de
communication je veux bien qu'on ait un
facebook européen mais en tout cas si
nous n'avons pas le contrôle
de tout ce que nous disions depuis tout
à l'heure au plan numérique au plan
industriel au plan technologique au plan
culturel au plan littéraire artistique
culturel et bien nous sommes condamnés à
prendre les objets des outils des autres
et donc quelque part à nous laisser
colonisé par une forme de mondialisation
qui n'a rien à voir avec notre identité
donc affirmer notre identité c'est aussi
affirmer notre identité culturelle dès
le plus jeune âge
malheureusement c'est déjà la fin dans
cette entrevue politique où nous avons
pu aborder différents points relatifs au
souverainisme qui n'ont qu'une idée peu
partagé à gauche mais qui est pourtant
intéressante à aborder dans le cadre
notamment d'une campagne présidentielle
on espère que cet entretien aura
intéressé notre éditeur et on les invite
à retrouver les 12 épisodes précédents
sur notre chaîne youtube scopeo
l'observatoire politique et retrouver
tous nos articles sur notre site
internet scopeo point org et donc merci
beaucoup à vous monsieur paul melin
venant de scopeo pour le merci à vous je
remercie de notre invitation
merci beaucoup